there's one fire exit in this room you
need to evacuate the external fire hose
please help or wet or slippery in the
distance we have apologies from
councillor missiles including just four
members no counselor Gooding has
replaced counselor Wilson my fortune
accounts for getting the comic in this
evening Jim dines number to substitute
members we have counselor mrs. wisdom
substitute for counselor villain and
counselor Merrick substitute or
counselor mrs. Gooding
taking Castle Williams the agenda item
for ministry meeting held on the 2nd of
July just for members to know that there
is a very very minor amendment to be
made to that in there
[Music]
Thank You mr. Jim there's also a slight
amazing I'd like to say on the community
button 1/3 for the Treasury report if
you remember I believe it was counseling
for skin but I'm not sure it wasn't the
correct to be amending to in future
reports it was there to be amended for
full counsel because it was actually
incorrect so so he was breakfast with
two full counsel yeah yeah there was an
appendix
yeah because we had to do it
ten points on five to receive
declaration of interest including any 15
declarations on culture if I need to
make a declaration that clear on our
county councillor how much of the ways
to recycling in something conjunction to
County Council so I think it no bikini
right it's so mr. chairman I'm afraid
I'm gonna have to go back to the minis
when we didn't even look to see if we
were attending but we weren't according
to you who we were
so both myself and counseling with mrs.
Carter well here I don't know what's
happening
apologies for bringing up to the gender
one to number six the reason you didn't
appear on the top because she was
something at that time oh yes yes but
when the ways to be sucked into a jet
was mentioned at the June meeting for
deciding whether to investigate further
during the 2013-14 you do support year
at this time one of the recommendations
from the committee was to win oceans
most vehicles in house though previously
they've been supplied by the contractor
in considering how the council will
become carbon neutral into thirteen
consideration will have to be given to a
waste contractor as there ways to be
able to make up a large part of the
council's fleet of vehicles the
emissions from these vehicles will form
a large element the council
to its members would have just and then
answer any questions thank you I won't
go for the body of the report I mean the
idea was it's a gives you a brief
overview of many of the aspects would
have to be considered in a new waste
contract and in many ways I felt it was
a suitable sort of thing for review in
that it's a service that affects every
resident across people and so it's
something that's a very high value as
well I said and and what I'm really like
a cities in the recommendations it's
like looking forward in terms of working
group to look at this there you know it
needs a separate group thing to look at
this in some detail over at some length
of time so it was really to give it just
a taste of what people will be learning
themselves in for in terms of the except
for working group should of course I
recommend a too much character I've only
gone is every aspect too but there's
quite a few key ones they owed you'd
always be repeating than qualified for
going through that these fake questions
council Thank You chairman and thanks
for that a good report quite
comprehensive couple of things one thing
that's not on there I think he's the
police that we do for residents who are
incapacitated or vulnerable I think it's
in six hundred we can do up to in the
contract I know it's not that many that
we actually do but I know where we have
residents who have problems maneuvering
the bins we can nominate them to
actually have that service where
appropriate and I think that should be
included
new contract and secondly I think things
like vehicles and timing I think of the
things that really need to be considered
because as you may know with the last
continuity for the baby so we own the
vehicles and - whether we need to do
that again and what stage we need to do
that and of course the length of the
contract itself and then you possible
the renewal you know proposal if you
like that comes forward with that - and
that's that there is an opening points
towards making this stage Chancellor I
don't if you want to say battle for that
I think I mean I think I'm currently
around 500 pronounced yeah so you know
it's a date but it's something that um
any contract with governess of quality
and diversity impact assessment we
probably have to suck it in that
consideration related era many aspects
thing I could have written tons of up
front of you quick brief overview
visited I think you'd have to look great
each aspects is in some detail the
working group and then moves forward
instead of please please it's quite a
detailed and in quite a lot on my road I
notice that they should be incorrect
into bins and placement back where they
possibly collect them I've got flats
next door to me and I can turn to and
say every week they leave the pins on
the road you sometimes
being on the road might be never ever
insane position so I don't know if this
is all inclusion all this and it has
quite a lot down the road I don't know
if it happens any other areas means I
never seem to be collected and the same
position at all a particular issue of
course we'd have to how we were the
specification sort of how it can be
addressed in terms of having criteria
sitting in awarding the contract it'll
reflect those concerns there is and
there is something to be wired up
between the quality and the cost of
times there are currently no cousins but
in terms again if the review wants to
visit that but I could be quite honest
about what we're the difficulties are
and in focusing that back on policy
Thank You chairman and form on page six
point three four point five for
recycling materials moment 15 K which
obviously is a huge carbon footprint I
presume that is right and it's up for
renewal so if the no passivity nearer to
us is the first question you'll be
testing my geography on where these are
based I mean that there aren't too many
things around there's one up in Suffolk
I think there's one on the edge of
London but again it's it's who wins the
contracts of the times it's where they
want to take the work on as well so very
topical with breakfast in the moment you
know that these contracts I think we're
a great day this is exported all
they rely on export markets as well then
there's some nervousness around these
contracts at times though I wouldn't say
we have many bidders or I'll actually
delivering the service three point six
of this report does refer to it says
this agreement was required by the
county so this is for the residual waste
so you refuse is taken Suzie's but not
recycling it is taken out down to
Madison they they still sort it to some
degree so they say they can rescue any
other recyclates out of that for
anything compact the rest for and then
that song for incineration small nothing
saying nuggets or not not it's not like
it's not pellets sorry the small pets
like compact inside so they used to be
incinerator that's the idea so they did
but it's a separate area if you wish for
that that's where our digital waste goes
the answer just that the contract you've
renew within the next twelve months so
this is separate to this contract it is
yes and how long will it take to tender
one so I mean I mean I'm I'm meeting
with existing contra to next week
discuss this anyway so it so we're
looking for these back out to tender
fairly soon so it's not such a long
tender processes say the waste contract
in itself but you know until doing
better fruitfulness time you see where
them where I was to look at this servant
I would be a review that this will be a
short-term contract again and I suspect
and runs at the end of the the existing
series contracts
and so if we minded to wrap the two
together at that point we can do so my
last question is do we know where all of
our rubbish ends up it's all great
saying there goes overseas what they're
doing I don't think we do have detailed
analyses of of where things are or
export it to and what sort of recycle
streams and how much is kept in the
country so Parador provide that D so my
point is the point which we can send to
any country but inland we do pay
attention already and certainly we're
positive the adora offer one of the
better contractor to these sort of
things so they've got a very transparent
and traceable to all the trail so they
they they take this to the reputation
quite seriously as well too late they
tend to minimize you know that they're
seeking the highest prices if you wish
to recyclates whether they came so the
landfill would be the least of their
suitable options themselves as well I
mean we can provide that break down the
community center and obviously a lot of
people that use it push chairs because
the number of bins are all on the
pavement and they should be on people's
property and also a lot of people in
wheelchairs they are forced to go into
the middle of the road on dustbin day
because the pavement is chopped up upper
bins so that's one concern the other one
is an calm parks are our compost recycle
bins
not sort of them though
so in what we do is where we have
success
the bring banks say that that is their
heavily used and they remain in place
where there isn't such an uptake or we
have some anti social issues with them
and they tend to be removed see now but
but but we but if they're successful
then of course we keep there wouldn't be
any reason not so but you know there are
times when someone particularly
underused or you know gain if they set
light so should we say you know on a
semi-regular basis you don't meet them
they're being we know how many issues
for a long time now encourages people to
recycle and think more about it no not
so hand I don't I mean I can't find
everything there is a specification it's
not always satisfactory how in regular
entity and sometimes I think in fairness
to them they can they can put a schedule
in and find it that for some unexplained
reason it was he started taking into a
bring bank so they do overflow sometimes
but there's a reference to that
internally by ourselves
no that's that's usually somebody
external independent consultant because
it because it's um you going to think
Genki from post at the same time if
you're saying that your team compliant
yourself
this will need to be reviewed yes
preferably Barney's self-deluded
technique Whitesburg so are we getting
an independent expert to review
depending no sorry to be clear sorry
it's not clearly I'm sorry the future
contract so when we decide how we want
to set up a new contract it would be
advised to have that super set to that
point again because what you're saying
is that it's not technically
environmentally economically practical
to do so right well if when we will
review the contracts how do we know that
so the tea isn't being reviewed it's
going to gain it yes sorry the council
currently receives a bonus payment of 16
what is the sixty nine thousand it's it
was four as a slaw meaning convoluted
formula which they use and at times I
won't confess to completely
understanding it but it was used and
synthesized to sort of go above and
beyond the certain level of Riesling I'm
saying I'm saying in terms of so we
could be awarded that for our green
whites there's much as down dry recycle
it was almost in terms of day again
you've gone above and beyond a certain
tonnage well done and it's a payment per
ton but that tonnage payment is
producing over the years down to zero in
2020
councils to go potty on when a time your
girls are expected to go at Bottenfield
that there would still be a fixed
tonnage of payment for dry recyclates no
there's also separate payment beyond
that as well so there are three payments
involved in to make that clear it's the
tape assessment basic concluded last
time that it was an ideal scenario what
we should be doing is collecting every
waste stream set aside so you should be
touching the bottom separately you sort
of paying for your wee plastic
separately but the reality of that is
it's not economic to do so and that's
where the assessment comes in so what
I'm saying is in the context of this we
were to make instruction separate
purpose objects into glass paint from
plastic what I'm saying is if you to do
so then tape assessment would need to
conclude with the violin or not or not
that makes sense
you know it's always an ideal situation
to get to but you may not be able to do
so once you've actually done the maths
of the contracts is we just can't afford
to do these separate collections and
that's where the assessment comes in you
need someone's coming and concluding so
actually what you're asking for you is
way beyond what it's reasonable in terms
of costs for counsel because it's but
I'm reading 3.48 or things there's any
reference to team is a positive
reference is that everything is okay but
then when I'm 86 point botanist and the
tepees has been concluded that the
collection of separate questions was not
viable well that's not mentioned
it's two sides of the same coin but I do
see someone saying that basically yes
that we conclude that to be clear them
the tape assessment is in the first
reference saying basically that it's
that it's acceptable to co-mingle what
they're saying is that it's not viable
to take effect on a separate thing
either 6.45 references to it as not as a
separately I think saying the tip system
concludes that you can't do that and
actually the better ends of our our view
of code mingling protection was the
correct way to do so he said that
clearly we were already commingling the
collection at the time so we were had or
we're already collecting in that way
when this when this legal legislative
sort of ruling came in so at that point
you do take possession say well is your
existing collection service accessible
you go yes it is you know the
commingling was acceptable when you look
to the future what you'll be saying is
are you able to collect these separately
it should be the starting point because
you're reviewing a new it's a new
starting point and to take protection of
may still saying actually you know you
can afford to do so and that's that's
the subtle difference okay Mike German
just for clarity that was a great bonus
council wasn't it report came to the
council it's the only map when it when
absolutely
so is that she also approved by the
council particularly each time and yeah
I definitely don't bring your attention
to it's only a word yeah but I don't
mean a lot to you because it will mean a
lot to residents that you've caught the
riot II of klaxon caravan can you change
that to mobile homes because of your
phone mobile
yes of course is that something anything
in the report this cabin can you change
it to our homes just one more thing
clearly we don't know what future
legislation I understand it maybe
legislation that requires us to take the
food waste is completely separately but
I believe the council was hard to get
conversation for those that don't do it
separately it was something on I think
with any contract or any consideration
to a contract needs to make sure it
keeps pace with the legislation that
comes forward from the government so we
have to have something in place that
actually takes that into account I don't
know if you've thought through you
believe you oh please all through there
- yes I mean I've I know there's any
more
Steve from central government with
spring there are suggestions at the
moment that they want to diffuse it up
we have a government yeah so suggest
that so there's any separate Corrections
possibly of garden waste and then
possibly and again looking at the the
you get this infection of garden waste
will be challenged or not challenged but
that there are strong suggestion that
the food collection will be set for it I
think that's a myth if they're very keen
to do the rest I think that the
reviewing again I think like say the key
thing is easy to ensure that we've
costed up on various options as well so
we understand the impact quite early on
begins as soon as it comes outside then
you have to think into the contract yeah
thank you sure is probably along the
same lines it's got to come off really
it's about future changes in recycling
behavior and shopping behavior compass
years is starting to be ended and I have
done it myself free where people may
start to leave packaging at shops I'm
certainly people been returning plastic
bottles to shops
ordered hell so if the
how much of the cost of the cost of this
is based on the quantity of weight of
recycling and if that changed would that
affect that the contract potentially is
that fixed or within the contract again
I think it depend on how the contract
set up hmm
I think it'd be unusual to have a
contract done one ton in July I think we
could we could look into that the great
majority that companies almost within
the physically having to drive around
see it doesn't rain too much based on
waking it changes line you'd be having
for quite a significant shift so you
know what you can then do if you're only
doing one run to the tip rather than to
the refuse truck then then there isn't
even that's about right and they on the
half extra time to sort of reflecting so
so it will have an impact at that point
but you know if it's a few tons here or
there it doesn't send them a great deal
of difference and but it just gets the
critical tipping points and again that's
what you need to work it out quite
carefully you know you get over a
certain tonnage you just need home your
vehicle there is only so much the
vehicle can clicks unit and then also
you need to know another a whole new
round so the it can be quite hard I
think the contractors world targeted
cost accurately so could I just thought
from the ones as was just internet since
the we have the same number of vehicles
that this contract started with at the
moment
Reserve me there's a significant amount
of housing being built and would have
been built by the end of this contract
would you envision that needing an extra
refusing truck at the moment or not well
it's something we're looking into detail
there with the contract among because
the contract would tell you yes but
we're not convinced that the rounds are
running as well as they could do and so
we've asked for a sum of rationalization
assessments of the rounds in terms of
you know
the routing of them and how the work is
divided and we think there's enough
capacity an existing contract I could
see the bet as well that we should be
able to accommodate the the growth in
the next couple of years whether the
existing resource is enough for the new
contracts is it you know looking forward
for another site 7415 you
he's a tougher question to answer and
again together that's why it would
depend on how we want to collect what we
want to collect you know the meetings
vary as well what people's want to use
and they make some differences at times
points around some of the community
projects are out there and I think that
there should be some snow in France as a
council to be looking at those
especially when you go organizations
like TerraCycle we even take chris
packets now because the more we can
encourage schools community groups
except to recycle recycle then it's
going to lower the tonnage and presuming
that this isn't too far away you've
already started to make inquiries are
there any such things as electric bin
lorries out there on you there are they
on the reliability is something I've me
talk more about but a bumming that they
think they do exist yes how expensive
are they I don't like it I mean but I
mean they clearly a lot more expensive
you know there's no two ways about it
but again the cost of means come down so
you know I mean you know we mentioned it
the street sweeping electrics three
actually always comes in at the same
cost so you know that's the cost song
begins come down there and just just one
more question because
that heads to our reducing carbon
footprint etc would there be funding
available for that sort of thing it's
something I have to look into it I'm not
familiar with funding for the refuse
vehicles this stage it's a possibility
that's it but again it's why to good
subject we looked at my review I think
because there is there are so many
variables to to weigh up in terms of
what you want from this contract how on
earth is the working party going to get
access to all the latest variation as
technical aspects that are on not being
for seated mothers I I know exactly that
can of worms you so on how on earth can
we I mean even if we just sort of say
what we need we're gonna have blue beans
for whatever then immediately we have a
different truck because once we thought
can take the smaller building so how can
we have access and I don't quite know
where we start in the working party
because we would spend a couple of weeks
working on a on and off a load of ideas
you can say thanks that doesn't work
because of this and there will be stuff
that you know that we will quite naively
plow ahead and you you taste will
actually we can't do that we use no
viable it's not this it's not that so I
think we somewhere along the line I know
we've got this report and it's very
comprehensive but I think I think we
need as a working group and I'm from ups
and our money or anything like that but
to have some sort of plan points to to
assess it so that we we can actually try
and get our teeth into otherwise we say
we're just going to go now it's got
other questions at arms
yeah that's probably the case yeah maybe
they even if someone have to attend I
was working party means I think discuss
ability I think we visit a visualizer
yes attending those and I think what we
may work do is say that's what you
wanted to look at we then go away and
have an officer group that also looked
at this is when we more detail comes
back but you know it is just an overview
and I think we have done was have a
plain sight we'll look at one expect at
a time so for example publicly why
should everyone our specs where like say
our charities can offer the facility to
click bulky works as well as we can and
is that empty one to investigate this is
starting nail on a contract that I don't
anticipate this being a very quick
conclusion I suspect this has to be done
in bite-sized chunks and when we go to
feeding bite-sized chunks you know what
our recommendations are
refers to the place in view do you know
or possibly places what the average kind
of lifespan of these is because it
seemed to me soon I mean I mean sort of
7 to 8 years is good going 10 10 years
between to the other end so I mean so
when the so these vehicles could be
available for the new contracts however
I think a contract will be very cautious
about taking money so they might say
thank you very much if they're available
but I don't think they'd want to price a
contracts on the strip for those Iranian
vehicles there was an unknown at that
age the backs then begin to rot out and
then surprisingly demanding you know the
white space or the holder Alex was there
is yeah yeah so I'm so 7 to 8 years is
this sort of I agree it's a good idea 7
years I'm just concerned about its
offices time because I know for well how
difficult they ease for them to do other
jobs because about projects I've been
talking to them about I can't even look
at them at the moment cuz they are so so
busy my my concern will be literally how
much time you want these offices to
spend on these things because I just
think they just update I've just I'm
teaching them in it other than that I
think it's a good idea don't you clear I
think I'm fuses probably wants my top
priority over the next couple of years
because of the expenditure of this you
know 2 million pound contracts
significant spend to the council we need
to get absolutely lines so you know to
fulfill my point of view it's one of the
priorities I will have
well how's that finger being reached is
that based on previous cost it's based
on a couple of thority some kid that had
signed it's also a similar thing done so
so sometimes a taped assessment so I
think that's right again I'd like them
to be a reduced cost from last time but
you could be looking at some of them up
so at 12,000 pounds now the race was
very much about the looking at the
rounds actually breaking you down cost
now the market price is what what did
expect the market to frighten and and so
so by the end of what you've got there
is an overview of your contracts in
terms of the results the exam and the
running cost of doing so but quite
accurate as well do you need that with
the various scenarios if so if you said
I want to look at you know food rice it
was like this is the compass I want to
look at this this is the cost and it and
they're using market you know current
market prices and current contracts have
been to the reward in the last two to
three years you know I won't have the
knowledge that know how that
if this Committee recommends that amount
to council is that amount then I'm an
assumedly the process will then go out
to tender in order to it's just me I
mean it's a standing of contracts I'm
sorry only reason I'll pull with of
course in okay in terms any other
contract you know price that you said
well I've come back with yeah but I mean
memory of the contract procedure rules
that their ability to vary and and and
again the sort of a the section one five
one some ability to vary as well it's
reasonable but you know if it's a
significant cost and you have to revisit
it but I anticipate this being broken
down into smaller chunks and this I'm
not going to come back down there we go
we've got a consultant in here's a bill
from the start sort of thing I are going
to submit this being over 18 months and
they'll be paying the stage payment so
we would soon have some idea of what the
costs
so your charity seriously normal
critical critical mass if you like okay
and they will be Telstra finish
presumably something that will carry on
yeah until we actually get yeah um it
would be called working group there
because then they don't have to meet in
public if they have to meet him public
everything a big PMC anyway the same as
the old would be place he started was
yeah because they'll be figures as well
yeah yeah you couldn't bring out like
you Jeff confidential information either
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
remember
[Music]
there is it
we're sort of looking at some more
supply guests prior signs are
prioritizing sort of the enforcement in
terms of which things to dress first but
I guess it's just kind of been
conversations it was almost ready to go
because driving and then we looked at a
couple of authorities that their
interest we were addressing when they
give advice of energy challenge for
doing some and it's clear what happens
when enforcement we find that they put
in their application okay
we revise them for an application and
you're always giving them free
pre-emptive vollis but first someone
hasn't enforced you know for someone
that has been performed with planning
law
contrary to those the law abiding could
be putting in for a free open and the
planning so what we look at me doing is
seeing how we can catch that within the
policy to say we know right you've got a
police planning application it will give
you some advice but we will be charging
you for doing so as we've done anyone
else you know it's a it's a misnomer so
that's what we want to get the wording
right before it comes back in it's just
something that came to them about
payments and lights as an opportunity
almost a lot last minute so I thought it
was personal screen now rather than
bring back inside something yes thank
you
I mean I've heard the officers comments
like I said it takes three months to
just tweak it however look at the
concern at that you know and it is
really important to document any to the
porch of the policy I don't know about
other members but at the moment I'm
getting more residents complaints and
concerns on enforcement than I am on
actually on planning
so when this policy is house I think
it's something that we should look at of
the removed image something it's
something we should add to our work it
really is an important document
[Music]
monitor
remember chef
all right after that we have the people
in communities important policy which is
still scheduled for October
tremendous service provision initially
that's
and then the only new one on there 12:19
is the tendency strategy 20 19 20
three down any more detail on that
Tennessee strategy I mean I know there
are quite a few issues with the
registered providers the housing stock
there's some concerns do you know little
more detail on what they're looking at
my friend i I don't at this point
becomes whole things I could ask the
assistant yes that would be great thank
you
don't watch my work
well the 16th of july 2019 council
resolved that a newbie to be asked to
set up across the party book understand
the implications and recommend deposits
my handle now that's been added to
I'm adding it under number to the
additional work amends to be considered
a program that amount of stage three
snow artist studies Freitas in nominated
as the lead officer at the current time
to assist on this members some members
would also
Netta that came in yesterday that they
were copied into
around the planet so at this point I'm
really just assuming that medieval one
point members what
just sign up see
that automatically
between the last working
my idea
as the homages to great
I was just about to say she actually
bought this
I would like to commit very in her has
bearing in mind our tech so a minute
this is her first wish pencil counselor
could eat them seek treatment
any other news of this thing
September
in addition to the the
together two separate parties
but there would be some crossover those
mistake to think it was beneath there
yet Jenny wonder the last one
contributes so much to them
it is the members from there on the
wages that are all these and then
anybody anyone yeah
I think Max's
any stones
let it
what type is flying what excuse me it
can be just with the view to actually
thank you this group to cross party if
the defenders are in agreement has
suggested possibly providing members
from outside of this committee over the
acceptable children yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah obviously I'm the elect of October
we now have a planning enforcement it
mr. chairman you actually said make it
cross party but we do have some
independent members I presume you're not
excluding they know building previous
work no there's other independent
notices but just if you use the word
cocktail yes all members of council
thank you
and you didn't realize that that was the
next painting yes yes you know it is
it's there because it hasn't been
focusing that painting
so the October the 8th I put my brain
here I already got but again I'm gonna
get I'll add that one in because it's
really sort of the talk phone holder for
planning gear to attend to that times
now
20 years ago you know best if you can
entertain you okay something so I think
for the moment but if we can keep build
the working men for next month's subject
too important to hold up
yes the next bit off I'll have to twist
someone's own